wir sagen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live euro um ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und die diskussion zur zeit was corona
angeht dreht sich vor allem um die
impfstoffe wurden zu wenig bestellt
hätten mehr geliefert werden können das
ist die eine seite aber auch natürlich
eine ganz große frage wie würden die
eigentlich die unterschiedlichen
impfstoffe was haben wir dazu erwarten
welcher impfstoff wird am besten gegen
mutationen und wie kommen wir jetzt
eigentlich bis september hin mit den
impfungen
das sind alles sachen die wir gerne
besprechen wollen heute mit euch
zusammen und dem kollegen den theologen
martin stürmer den wir schon oft hier im
stream gehabt haben als experten
deswegen eure fragen bitte sehr gerne in
die dafür vorgesehenen spalten oder per
e mail an zdf heute.de zdf.de ich werde
dann gucken was wir damit in den stream
rein nehmen können damit wir am ende
dieser jahr 20 bis 30 minuten
hoffentlich alle ein bisschen klüger und
schlauer sind und weniger fragen haben
was das thema impfen an die aber jetzt
sage ich erst mal hallo guten abend herr
stürmer hallo grüße sie ich fange mal
bei was ganz rudimentäre man so ein
impfstoff der ist ja eigentlich doch
recht komplex haben wir jetzt immer
gelernt welche schritte sind eigentlich
notwendig um so ein impfstoff
herzustellen
ja da sind einige schritte notwendig man
muss erstmal ein einstand teil will erst
mal auf einen viralen impfstoff
irgendein bestandteil des virus kennen
der tatsächlich auch eine vernünftige
immunantwort bei uns in uns auslöst also
sprich irgendeine erkennungs
anerkennungs protein was wirklich dazu
führt dass wir antikörper bilden und im
nächsten schritt dann auch wenn das wie
das virus wieder kommt auch die
infektion verhindern können
und die sind diesen dieses baustein die
muss man erst mal identifizieren
dann muss man den produzieren auf
reinigen da kann man sich überlegen ob
man das ganze virus nimmt und es tötet
oder auch nur ein bruchteil nimmt
und das ganze im labor vervielfältigt
und wenn man das in der theorie und in
der praxis erst mal umgesetzt hat dann
muss man auch wirklich schauen ob das
beim menschen funktioniert und das macht
man in drei klinischen phase in dem man
erst mal probiert ob es überhaupt
funktioniert was man sich in der idee
ausgedacht hat das überhaupt antikörper
gebildet werden da muss man die richtige
dosis finden und dann muss man bei der
breiten gruppe an vielen vielen menschen
zeigen dass das tatsächlich gegen eine
erkrankung zum beispiel hilft das sind
ziemlich viele schritte und dann auch
noch ein relativ komplexer
herstellungsprozess wir jetzt immer
wieder hören da wird ja viel diskutiert
gerade eine dauert das zu lange haben
die impfstoffhersteller was falsch
verstanden oder was falsches versprochen
wie schauen sie eigentlich auf diese
debatte ja ich schaue damit etwas mehr
ja in anführungszeichen gelassenheit
drauf weil es ist tatsächlich so ist das
als wir angefangen haben impfstoffe zu
bestellen bei den verschiedenen
herstellern ja noch gar nicht wissen
konnten welcher von denen schafft es
denn überhaupt in die zulassung auch in
der phase 3 können immer noch also in
der letzten klinischen phase im stoffe
zurückgezogen werden wir haben jetzt
gerade am beispiel msd gesehen die haben
in der phase 3 erkannt dass ihr produkt
nicht die wirksamkeit erzielen wird wie
die anderen und haben das produkt
rausgenommen es wird nicht zugelassen
das konto kann vorher keiner wissen und
wenn man dazu einseitig einkauft kann
man auch böse auf die nase vorn hat gar
nichts und insofern finde ich das
vernünftig ja und indie und bei den
problemen bei der produktion da steckt
natürlich auch keiner im detail drin
wir wollen einen impfstoff haben von
höchster qualität ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig und wenn dann die
qualitätskontrollen ergeben im werk das
schaffen wir nicht da ist irgendwas
nicht sauber
dann muss man das auch respektieren egal
wie ärgerliches ist und als dritten
punkt wir haben jetzt mal blick die
schwerst zudem von der bevölkerung
vorgezogen
wir haben einen impfstoff der extrem
schwierig ist mit der logistik bei minus
80 grad
und da kann man nicht erwarten dass das
alles sofort glatt und reibungslos
funktioniert jeder der mal komplexe
prozesse organisiert hat der weiß dass
das wissen wir ja schon wenn wir
versucht mit tiefkühlpizza vorm laden
nach hause zu bringen ohne dass sie
auftaucht auftaut das ist ja schon
schwierig genug für uns jetzt habe ich
aber trotzdem gerade gelesen es
kurz vor der sendung rein in den
nachrichtenagenturen premierminister
johnson von den vereinigten königreich
großbritannien hat stolz mitgeteilt zehn
millionen menschen in großbritannien
sind jetzt schon gegen korona geimpft
das einen meilenstein
da können wir ja doch nur ein bisschen
neidisch drauf gucken gut sie haben
früher begonnen
sie haben sicherlich da etwas mehr und
der logistik vielleicht was anderes
gemacht
ja wir sind bei bei was kann die
aktuellen zahlen habe ich jetzt gerade
nicht verfolgt aber wir müssen sogar
knapp zwei millionen sein
silber erhalt faktor fünf drunter
tatsächlich nicht aber wir haben wie
gesagt gerade die die schwierigste
bevölkerung hinter uns die größte gruppe
und ich denke das werden wir jetzt in
die etwas leichtere gruppe gehen mit den
fünf zentren wenn wir auch sicherlich
relativ schnell aufholen so ich bevor
wir das noch mal wirklich ins detail
gehen uns die einzelnen impfstoffe
angucken uns die dazugehörigen filme
anschauen die die kolleginnen
vorbereitet haben gucke ich doch gleich
mal in den kommentare und seda einen
kommentar der relativ häufig kommt
sobald es um das thema impfungen geht
nämlich das stichwort langzeitstudien
wir können auf meinen rechner hier kurz
darauf gehen
da steht dann ne es gibt noch keine
langzeitstudien ich will kein
versuchskaninchen sein schreibt der user
mit einem unaussprechlichen nickname der
stürmer was ist denn daran also beim
impfen ist es in der regel so dass die
nebenwirkung direkt nach der injektion
oder kurz danach auftauchen wenn da
wirklich was gravierendes passieren
sollte dementsprechend wir haben wir
weltweit jetzt mit den verschiedenen
impfstoffen an die hunderttausend
menschen geimpft in den
unterschiedlichen studien mit den
unterschiedlichen impfstoffen und wenn
da was wirklich ganz gravierendes
gewesen wäre oder sein würde würden wir
das sofort ziehen
wir haben zwar ein paar fälle mit
schweren allergischen reaktionen gesehen
das waren menschen die aber an sich
schon hochgradiger allergiker sind und
das ist etwas was natürlich wichtig ist
zu wissen und aber das hat man sofort
gesehen und insofern wird es keine
weiteren großen überraschung gehen die
jetzt häufig auftauchen
und als ich fünf jahre nach der impfung
wird man keine keine nebenwirkungen mehr
sehen und insofern sind die studien zwar
noch nicht klar
aber das was wir gesehen haben erreicht
aus um das risiko entsprechend bewerten
zu können
wir schauen uns das mit den
nebenwirkungen auch nochmal gleich im
detail an da gibt es eine schöne story
bei uns auf zdf heute aber jetzt wollen
wir erst 19 überblick verschaffen welche
impfstoffe ist eigentlich gibt so ganz
grob wie unterscheiden die sich und da
hat meine kollegin die dfg was für uns
zusammengefasst
der impfstoff von baxter ist ein
sogenannter m rna impfstoff und wird in
deutschland seit weihnachten verimpft
der impfstoff schützt mit einer
wirksamkeit von bis zu 95 prozent er
kann bereits ab 16 jahren verabreicht
werden
auch der impfstoff von moderner basiert
auf einem rna und erreicht laut studien
eine wirksamkeit von 94 empfohlen wird
er für personen ab 18 jahren
ein neuzugang auf dem markt kommt vom
britisch schwedischen hersteller
astrazeneca die europäische
arzneimittelagentur gab letzte woche
grünes licht
im gegensatz zu den zwei anderen vakzin
ein sogenannter vector impfstoff
wie gut der impfstoff von astrazeneca
schützt hängt von der dosierung ab
in studien war bei durchschnittlich 70
der teilnehmer/innen wirksam die
wirksamkeit schwankt allerdings je nach
höhe der gespritzten dosis weitere
kandidaten machen hoffnung der impfstoff
von tür weg befindet sich seit ende
dezember 2020 in der zweiten von drei
zulassungsphase pure weg rechnet
spätestens im märz mit ergebnissen auch
aussichtsreich der johnson & johnson
impfstoff ist bereits in der dritten
phase der klinischen studien
laut einer weltweiten studie liegt die
wirksamkeit aber nur bei etwa 66 prozent
die zulassung könnte der nächsten wochen
kommen ja also gar nicht mal so
unkompliziert das ganze dadurch zu
blicken gerade für laien deswegen sind
wir heute hier sprechen mit dem
theologen martin stürner über die frage
was sind das eigentlich für impfstoffe
wie wirken die wir unterscheiden die
sich welche ist vielleicht auch das
beste oder der beste
die frage stellt sich gleich ich möchte
eine zahl kurz nachreichen herrscht
immer meine kollegen haben gerade ganz
fleißig recherchiert waren ganz schnell
weil wir wussten ja gerade nicht wie
viele menschen sind in deutschland jetzt
tatsächlich schon geimpft und ich kann
den aktuellen stand geben von heute
morgen 10 uhr laut rk ii waren das zwei
millionen 33.000 561 personen also 2,4
prozent der deutschen gesamtbevölkerung
die die erste impfung bekommen haben und
die zweite impfung und damit quasi haken
dahinter machen können
679 1649 personen das sind 0,8 prozent
der deutschen bevölkerung da sind die
briten uns doch wirklich ein bisschen
voraus muss man sagen die sind quasi mit
der ersten impfung bei den fünffach hin
jetzt haben wir gerade die verschiedenen
impfstoffe gesehen wir haben auch gehört
der von johnson johnson der hat zum
beispiel nur eine wirksamkeit von 66%
ich habe gerade mit einem halben auge
schon eine passende frage dazu gesehen
dass mal kurz schauen ob ich noch mal
wieder finde
genau hier auch immer gerne bei mir auf
den rechner schalten
was bringt mir uns eine impfung mit 50
60 maximal 70 prozentiger wirksamkeit
bei 100 prozent neben wirken und nach
wie vor großen spread risiko das ist
eine frage die gebe ich jetzt sehr gerne
ein stück weiter
[Gelächter]
welches große risiko wir haben
eigentlich mit einer impfung so gut wie
kein risiko irgendwas einzugehen
im gegenteil wir haben mit der impfung
eine große chance tatsächlich als
minimum was wir im augenblick ja ganz
eindeutig in den studien sehen
zu einem hohen prozentsatz die
erkrankung zu vermeiden was ja schon
sehr viel wert ist was definitiv dazu
beiträgt die gesundheitssysteme
insgesamt wieder zu entlasten dass die
sterberaten runtergehen und für jeden
einzelnen einfach eine gute chance von
der schweren symptomatik befreit zu sein
und ich will jetzt mal kurz vor greifen
heute kam mir eine veröffentlichung aus
großbritannien von massa zenica
impfstoff dass da auch hinweise es zu
geben scheint dass wir auch insgesamt
die übertragung des virus deutlich
reduzieren können insofern hat impfen
keine nachteile sondern eigentlich nur
vorteile
da können sie das vielleicht noch mal
ein bisschen auseinander klar zu sein
also da waren denkt ja wie ich jetzt mal
wirklich ohne medizinisches fachwissen
ich kriege die spritze in abend danach
dass alles gut ich kann mich nicht mehr
anstecken gar nichts passiert mehr
das ist er tatsächlich nicht ganz so
einfach da gibt es ja einmal diese das
fachwort der sterilen immunisierung was
was hat es damit auf sich können sie
gleich noch mal wirklich für anfänger
erklären ja wir können es auch wieder am
beispiel der studien hier machen die die
zum beispiel die biotech studie
was hat man gemacht man hat einen teil
der studien probanden mit natrium
chlorid oder was weiß ich irgendwas
games kochsalz die anderen mit dem
echten impfstoff dann hat man diese
menschen jeden tag gefragt wie geht es
euch habt ihr irgendwelche symptome wenn
die menschen gesagt haben ja ich habe
berufs verlust geschmacksverlust sicher
kopfschmerzen fieber oder irgendwas dann
wurden die einbestellt man hat ein
rachenabstrich genommen eine pc
untersuchung gemacht und dann hat man
geschaut wieviel positive fälle hat man
bei denen die im prinzip diese
kochsalzlösung bekommen haben wie viel
hat man bei denen die den echten dem
stoff bekommen haben dann hat aber diese
auswahl war nicht die pcr machen
rein auf klinische symptomatik gesetzt
dementsprechend kann man aus den studien
bis jetzt erst mal nur ableiten
dass der impfstoff in der lage ist mit
95 prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit den
ausbruch der erkrankung zu verhindern
dafür war die studie ausgelegt und das
sind die daten die wir haben und alles
andere ist jetzt erst im machen und wird
uns hoffentlich in kürze präsentiert
also in der nämlich dass nicht nur die
erkrankung verhindert wird sondern dass
ich nicht mal mehr virus produziere und
dementsprechend auch keine - weitergeben
kann das ist das wichtigste dass wir
haben vom tisch das heißt aber wenn ich
jetzt so höre johnson johnson die
wirksamkeit von um die 66 prozent heisst
das dass 66 prozent der menschen die den
impfstoff bekommen haben sich nicht also
keinen schweren verlauf einer krankheit
hatten
genau das ist erstmal das was in den
studien getestet wird
aber sie haben sich trotzdem im
infiziert das wissen wir nicht
wir wissen nicht ob die ob die anderen
probanden die ist jetzt nicht bekommen
haben oder die dass die daten sind nicht
darum wollen wir haben nur sind nur pc
untersuchen gemacht worden bei denen die
wirklich symptome hatten und alles
andere drumherum das sehen wir jetzt an
der britischen studie weist zwar zenica
was tatsächlich mit denen es die eben
nicht erkrankt sind haben die doch wie
wo es so zu sagen haben sich infiziert
und produzieren virus und sind nur ohne
symptome das ist die frage die
abschließend noch geklärt werden muss
aber die hinweise im augenblick gehen
darauf hin dass er tatsächlich auch eine
deutliche reduktion von überhaupt
infektionen sehen aber ich glaube ja
dass gerade bei skeptischen menschen die
dem ganzen irgendwie so ein bisschen
abwartend gegenüber stehen genau diese
statements die sie gerade gesagt haben
das wissen wir noch nicht da haben wir
noch keine daten zu erhoben
dazu führen dass diese skepsis noch
genährt wird können sie das mal
einordnen ob das vielleicht auch
berechtigt ist ja das problem ist
natürlich dass wir erst mal nur das
kommunizieren können was tatsächlich
auch gemacht worden ist ich kann ich
gehe davon aus dass wir tatsächlich
insgesamt auch den schutz vor der
infektion haben werden mein problem ist
eben aktuell ich kann ihnen nichts
versprechen was ich nachher nicht halten
kann und ich kann das nur kommunizieren
ich kann ich gehe davon aus dass wir zu
einem hohen prozentsatz auch wirklich
nicht ansteckend sind wenn wir gut sind
und das ist das was die studien jetzt
wohl auch zeigen
nicht zu den gleichen prozentsatz wie
jetzt der schutz vor der schweren
erkrankung ist aber da sind die daten
eben halt auch noch nicht vollständig
und müssen wir abwarten dann natürlich
kann ich jetzt die skeptiker verstehen
die sagen ja momente mal was nützt mir
das dann wenn ich gar nicht vor der
weitergabe des virus geschützt bin und
damit hat man natürlich erstmal recht
was die pandemieplanung angeht wollen
wir natürlich einen impfstoff haben der
auch dafür sorgt dass wir das virus
überhaupt nicht weitergeben können aber
da bin ich optimistisch von den ersten
daten die ich jetzt gerade gesehen haben
heute sieht das so aus als ob wir da
auch zu einem hohen prozentsatz erfolg
haben zumindest bei dem wirkstoff von
astrazeneca
zumindest von dem aber warum sollten es
bei den anderen dann nicht der fall sein
dann habe ich noch mal ne frage ist
längst ein bisschen gerade ab und ich
hoffe die kollegin regie kriegen jetzt
nicht schnappatmung weil wir haben noch
uns zu jedem wirkstoff einen eigenen
film hingelegt aber es passt gerade ganz
gut weil ich das bisschen das gefühl hat
dass auch mit dieser wirksamkeit dieses
in prozenten dass ein bisschen
missverstanden wird also ich habe mir
nämlich einen kommentar auf facebook
grad gefunden von frank mauersberger der
schreibt mit 60-prozentiger wirksamkeit
kannst du bestimmt nicht zu einem
konzert gehen da hatten wir ja heute die
diskussion das konzert weiter gesagt
haben
sie denken darüber nach konzerte für
geimpfte personen nur noch zu öffnen
zumindest für eine zeitlang also ist
diese aussage so korrekt mit
60-prozentiger wirksamkeit kannst du
nicht zu einem konzert gehen
ja es ist eine diskussion die ich mir
auch wieder viel zu früh kommt ich habe
diesen habe ich darauf gelesen habe mich
auch sehr darüber geärgert weil sie
kommt zu einer unzeit weil wir ihm viel
zu wenig noch wissen und wir können
nicht einfach tatsächlich im augenblick
mit dem impfpass durch die gegend rennt
und sagen ich kann niemanden mehr
anstecken weil ich hier bin
das zeigt uns diese zeigen uns die daten
noch nicht in der gleichen form die
frage bezahlen brauche ich dann später
mal eine bestimmung meines antikörper
status muss ich dir liebe laborbefund
sozusagen in der tasche tragen um
nachzuweisen dass sich ausreichend
antikörper schutz habe
da ist noch viel offen aber solche
diskussionen sind absolut nicht
förderlich was eben das vertrauen in die
impfung angeht und ich bin immer noch
der meinung auch wenn der nachwuchs
zeigt nur 60 prozent
besser als gar kein impfstoff das auf
jeden fall und man darf bei johnson &
johnson nicht vergessen die testen auch
eine einmal im strategie mit nur einem
schuss und parallel untersuchen sie aber
auch die zweifach impfung wenn der
wirklich deutlich besser ist dann wird
auch johnson & johnson wahrscheinlich
die zulassung für zwei mal impfen
beantragen
ich habe ja noch ein paar fragen die
tatsächlich sich mit diese wirksamkeit
und die sicherheit drehen die würde ich
gern noch mal mit rein nehmen
da geht es auch um astrazeneca gucken
was vielleicht noch mal im detail an
aber das passt eben auch wieder zu
dieser skepsis die man immer wieder bei
uns in den stream ist auch spürt und
sieht und die wir natürlich auch ernst
nehmen weil das sind fragen die kann man
sich stellen zum beispiel haben möchte
gabi auf facebook möchten wissen die
schweiz verschiebt die zulassung von
astrazeneca weil die daten nicht
ausreichen
bei uns ist es angeblich super kann mir
das mal einer erklären
ja wir haben ja auch in deutschland die
zulassung die empfehlung der
europäischen zulassungsbehörde nicht
eins zu eins übernommen
beim astra zenica impfstoff ist ziemlich
viel durcheinander in den studien
passiert man hat verschiedene
dosierungen gehabt also man hat
teilweise den ersten schuss mit einer
halben dosis gemacht und das ist alles
natürlich schwierig und die zusatz
behörden rechnen dann eben tatsächlich
alles raus was da nicht kommt und wenn
dann jetzt eine nationale behörde zu dem
schluss kommt die datenmenge reicht mir
nicht
dann ist das natürlich der
auslegungssache ich denke die daten
reichen an sich für die
normalbevölkerung aus wo eine gute
empfehlung abzugeben
aber ich stimme zum beispiel der stiko
also der ständigen impfkommission in
deutschland zu dass wir für die älteren
personen deutlich zu wenig daten haben
also ist die schweizer übersensibel oder
sind andere länder nicht vorsichtig
genug also ich würde jetzt eher sagen
dass die schweizer etwas zu sensibel ist
letztendlich sind die daten an sich die
für die standardisierung vorliegen nicht
ganz so von der fallzahl er so hoch wie
bei den anderen zulassungsstudien von
den anderen wettbewerbern aber meiner
meinung nach ausreichend
so jetzt haben wir viel über astra
zeneca gesprochen deswegen gucken wir
uns das noch mal im detail an wir haben
einen film vorbereitet von meiner
kollegin gucken das ist nicht nina
gewesen nein das ist genau das war der
kollege andreas staab wir haben so viele
filme heute gemacht da komme ich wissen
durch
wenn wir also der kollege andreas stamm
aus großbritannien wird den neuesten
erkenntnissen zu dem wirkstoff
astrazeneca zehn millionen geimpften
seit wochen läuft das größte
impfprogramm der britischen geschichte
nun liefert es eine erste antwort auf
eine zentrale frage schützen impfstoffe
nur davor schwer krank zu werden oder
verhindern sie auch dass man andere
ansteckt die entwickler des astra zeneca
impfstoffs von der universität oxford
kommen in einer studie zu einem klaren
ergebnis das allerdings von anderen
wissenschaftlern noch nicht überprüft
wurde
bis zu 67 prozent also zwei von drei
kämpfen können das virus nicht mehr
übertragen in deren wöchentlichen corona
tests konnte kein virus material
nachgewiesen werden wir sehen dass
geimpfte deutlich weniger corona
infektionen aufweisen da sie nicht
infiziert sind können sie andere auch
nicht anstecken was sehr wichtig ist um
die pandemie einzudämmen
eine weitere erkenntnis der studie eine
verschiebung der zweiten impfung sei
unbedenklich
die erstimpfung führe zu einer
wirksamkeit von 76% schütze also fast
acht von zehn geimpften nach drei
monaten ohne zweite dosis bleibt der
schutz genauso hoch um schnell viele
bürger zu schützen bei knappen vorräten
hatte die britische regierung
entschieden die zweite dosis nicht wie
empfohlen drei sondern zwölf wochen
später zu verabreichen was sich als
glücksgriff heraus zu stellen scheint
denn durch das spätere impfen steige die
wirksamkeit sogar die ergebnisse noch
vorläufig sollten geimpfte tatsächlich
wesentlich weniger ansteckend sein
es wäre ein meilenstein in der pandemie
bekämpfung ja da stellt sich die frage
martin stürner virologe ist damit
astrazeneca obwohl sie schwierigkeiten
mit den studien mit der studienlage
hatten und dass er jetzt auch ein
bisschen hin und her mit der lieferung
mit dem die fonds termin gab sind sie
damit der gewinner
sie haben zumindest als erstes die daten
publiziert dazu damit haben sie
sicherlich ein vorsprung vor den anderen
ich gehe aber davon aus dass wir das
welche daten auch von den anderen
impfstoff hersteller noch bekommen
werden
man muss das ein bisschen mit mit
zurückhaltung noch interpretieren weil
die ergebnisse noch nicht geprüft sind
von unabhängigen gutachtern aber die
daten sprechen für sich wir haben hat
aber auch hier wieder das problem dass
diese zwei drittel schutzwirkung
hochgerechnet auf alle dosierungen
wir haben ja in der europäischen union
eine zulassung für zwei mal volle dosis
im abstand von bis zu zwölf wochen wenn
ich es richtig im kopf habe und hier ist
in diesem 67 prozent sind auch die die
mit einer niedrigen dosierung gestartet
sind eingerechnet
jetzt habe ich hier auch wieder
skeptische kommentare auf facebook zum
beispiel von andrea hieß schösser die
schreibt kaum gibt es in einigen ländern
gewisse vorbehalte gegen den impfstoff
von astrazeneca und er wird nicht für
alle altersgruppen empfohlen wo wunder
jetzt auf einmal ist er doch so super er
soll dafür sorgen dass geimpfte nicht
mehr ansteckend sind sputnik wie
bekommen wir gleich noch wieder
hessische russische impfstoff erst
verteufelt jetzt hoch gelobt irgendwie
ist das alles nicht sehr
vertrauenswürdig das ist natürlich der
fall
es wird er so über den dämmstoff
gesprochen dann so wie können sie das
jemand erklären denn nicht zu tief drin
steckt in dieser ganzen medizinischen
debatte ja das ist sicherlich immer
schwer nachzuvollziehen man muss immer
sehen auf welchem datensatz die ganzen
profil ab wir haben hier ein
zulassungsverfahren was was laufenden
prozesse ist ein sogenanntes rowling
circle verfahren also die
zulassungsbehörde bekommt immer wieder
neue daten von dem hersteller zu
geliefert und passt aufgrund dieser
daten entsprechend die zulassung an in
der ersten runde hat die europäische
union oder die epa die europäische
zulassungsbehörde entschieden dass man
den impfstoff vollumfänglich zu lassen
kann in der standardisierung für alle
altersgruppen
da waren die nationalen behörden etwas
anderer meinung was ich gerechtfertigt
findet jetzt kommen neue daten die
werden ja auch immer wieder neu
produziert und ausgewertet das ist nicht
so dass die erst gestern sozusagen
generiert worden sind und die sind
prinzip heute veröffentlicht worden das
heißt aber die lagen schon vor die
mussten nur zusammen geschrieben werden
vernünftig ausgewertet werden auch das
sind wissenschaftliche prozesse die ihre
zeit brauchen und die eigentlich ganz
normal sind man fängt an mit den ersten
daten liefert die nächsten daten und und
und das ist ein laufender prozess man
lernt immer mehr dazu
man teilt diese daten mit der mit der
zulassungsbehörden und sozusagen mit den
medien mit der öffentlichkeit das ist
aber normalerweise eben nicht der fall
normalerweise berichten wir ja jetzt in
den nachrichten in den medien erst
darüber werden quasi man ganz am ende
mit diesem prozess ist und jetzt
bewerbungsprozess quasi beim entstehen
zu jetzt haben wir gerade schon den
russischen impfstoff sputnik wie
angesprochen der auch erst mit skepsis
betrachtet wurde als er letztes jahr im
august in russland das erste mal
verimpft wurde weil es eben nicht viele
daten gab jetzt heute heißt es oder die
neueste erkenntnis ist erscheint eine
relativ hohe im volks am kai zu haben
und meine kolleginnen annika kuhl hat
das mal für uns auseinandergenommen in
russland gefeiert von europa kritisch
beäugt sputnik wie wurde in russland
schon im august vergangenen jahres
freigegeben als erster impfstoff
weltweit
die studienergebnisse damals
unvollständig die wirksamkeit unklaren
jetzt aber bestätigt eine renommierte
britische fachzeitschrift die
wirksamkeit ist hoch konkret 91,6
prozent
dazu kommt es budnik wie ist ein vector
impfstoff und kann bei kühlschrank
temperaturen gelagert werden anders als
etwa die maxime von biotech und moderner
angewendet wird der russische impfstoff
inzwischen in mehr als 15 ländern
weltweit auch in ungarn
obwohl er in der eu noch gar nicht
zugelassen ist das soll sich aber ändern
zumindest hat russland die eu zulassung
im januar offiziell beantragt möglich
also dass budnik wie bald auch in
deutschland verkauft wird
darüber sprechen wir mit dem virologen
martin stürmer in frankfurt herrscht
immer war das fahrlässig von der
russischen regierung diesen impfstoff
frei zu geben obwohl es im grunde keine
daten lange gab ja es war zumindest dann
hohes risiko für die gesundheit der
jugendlichen stoff bekommen haben das
war ist ungewöhnlich dass man einen
impfstoff zulässt ohne dass er durch die
große klinische phase 3 prüfung geht und
dementsprechend haben wir auch alle
gesagt das ist der zeitpunkt wo man sich
mit dem stoff nicht impfen lassen
würde ich habe genau das gleiche gesagt
das liegt nicht daran dass dem stoff
schlecht ist oder ich ihn von vornherein
als schlecht eingestuft habe nur weil er
aus russland kommt sondern weil einfach
keine daten dazu vorliegen und das ist
das entscheidende kriterium
hier gibt es jetzt auch die frage so wie
ist der einzuschätzen also ist das
tatsächlich ist ein ganz anderer
wirkstoff also wie kommt es dass das
auch die wirksamkeit so unterschiedlich
ist also können sie vielleicht noch mal
kurz erklären wo da tatsächlich jetzt
die medizinischen unterschiede sind ja
also wir können am besten hier
astrazeneca und und den russischen
sputnik wie im stoff vergleichen beide
sind vector impfstoffe beide benutzen
also hilfs viren um das eigentliche eben
protein das oberflächenprotein von lars
koch 2 zu transportieren
während der astra zenica zweimal den
gleichen virus wird das gleiche wie es
benutzt in der ersten und in der zweiten
als aushilfs virus benutzt hat der
russische impfstoff zwei
unterschiedliche helfer viren und das
mag einen kleinen unterschied sein weil
man sich ja vorstellen kann wenn ich mit
einem hilfsfonds sozusagen geimpft werde
wird auch da unser immunsystem erkennen
moment das gehört in meinen körper nicht
rein und gegebenfalls antikörper gegen
dieses hilfs virus produzieren und damit
die effizienz in der zweiten impfung
gegebenfalls reduzieren astra celik hat
er die besten ergebnisse wenn die beiden
dosen weit auseinanderliegen das kann
damit durchaus zusammenhängen und beim
sputnik wie haben wir eben zwei
unterschiedliche viren das heißt wenn
das zweite mal geimpft wird haben wir
wieder einen virus was das immunsystem
gar nicht kennt und damit kann es besser
funktionieren jetzt gibt es hier
wirklich jede menge fragen ich habe mir
wissen versucht rhein zu gucken die in
sehr unterschiedliche richtungen gehen
ich würde nochmals zu dieser wirksamkeit
zurückgehen weil das wirklich etwas ist
was viele menschen umtreibt die dann
diese zahlen im kopf haben und ich bin
mir jetzt als laie nicht ganz sicher ob
das gerade sachen verglichen werden die
man miteinander vergleichen kann hier
mal exemplarisch die frage warum braucht
man eine impfung die zu 95 prozent hilft
ich würde mal übersetzen wirksam ist für
eine krankheit in deren eine
überlebenschance von 99,8 prozent hat
kann man diese beiden zahlen miteinander
zu vergleichen der stürmer sollte sollte
man nicht tun weil worum geht es es
sterben
jetzt uns mal gucken was wir was wir
sehen wir haben eine eine übervolle
intensivstationen
wir haben sehr viele menschen die jeden
tag sterben an dieser infektion
jeder der sich impfen lässt wird dazu
beitragen nach dem was wir jetzt aus der
astra zenica studie gelesen haben dass
wir das virus nicht weiter gehen werden
das werde ich jetzt oder apostol ich mal
auf die anderen impfstoffe drüber
das heißt man tut erst mal als gangster
vor allem da was gut ist dass man
vermeidet das virus weiter zu bringen
man tut aber auch wenn das nach den
bisherigen daten was für sich selber
weil ich kann natürlich nicht
garantieren dass ein junger mensch nicht
schwer krank wird oder verstärken kann
auch da haben wir genug fallbeispiele
gesehen und das ist natürlich immer ein
russisches roulette mit zwar etwas mehr
als sechs kugel im lauf aber es ist
nicht so unwahrscheinlich dass auch ein
junger menschen schweren verlauf bringen
kann
und den kann man auf jeden fall mit
einer impfung russisches roulette in
zusammenhang mit russischen impfstoff
fantastische niedrig das schwierige
kombination da wollen wir jetzt nichts
insinuieren was irgendwie da ist nicht
so gemeint nicht machen ihre weiter mit
skeptischen stimmen die wir haben dafür
sind wir eben auch da um diese fragen zu
beantworten hier gibt es eine frage von
tagen auf youtube stimmt es dass
geimpfte gibt die dann doch noch positiv
getestet wurden
ja es gab in den studien tatsächlich
auch menschen die trotz zweier impfungen
entsprechend noch später die erkrankung
auch bekommen haben auch einen schweren
verlauf
diese fälle muss man genau aufarbeiten
und sehen was da letztendlich dazu
geführt hat dass das passiert wir haben
ja eine wirksamkeit die eben nicht 100
prozent ist sondern eben eine
anführungszeichen nur 95 prozent aber es
gibt tatsächlich vereinzelt fälle die
trotz impfung entsprechend auch
erkranken können aber gibt es denn
impfstoff generell die eklige arzt die
100 prozent wirksam sind
es ist eigentlich eher seltener und wenn
wir uns mal die die influenza-impfung
immer als gutes beispiel angucken weil
es eine ähnliche übertragungsweg ist mit
der wir uns ja eigentlich schon auch
sehr gut auskennen da haben wir 60 70
schutzwirkung insofern sind diese
impfstoffe jetzt aktuell wie die vector
impfstoffe pd
vergleichbar was wir kennen und die mrsa
impfstoffe sogar deutlich drüber
insofern haben wir eine sehr sehr gute
schutzwirkung ist markt für den
einzelnen mal nicht funktionieren
aber wir müssen halt immer uns ein
bisschen davon lösen immer nur als als
ich zu denken sondern ein bisschen auch
bei solchen strategien an die
gesamtbevölkerung denken so jetzt kommen
wir mal zur großen frage der
nebenwirkungen
da habe ich mal auf unsere zdf heute app
eine story aufgemacht sind wir hier im
hintergrund und die können sie und ihr
euch auch in aller ruhe angucken die
gezahlt wie gesagt in der zdf-reihe oder
auch zdf heute.de auf die stories gehen
da gibt es nämlich genau zu den koreaner
impfstoffen die jeweiligen
nebenwirkungen da kann man einfach durch
scrollen und kann sich zum beispiel mal
angucken was die nebenwirkungen beim
contact pfizer impfstoff sind da steht
dann hier zum beispiel 60 prozentige
abgeschlagen aber 60 prozent der
probanden haben gesagt sie haben für
deine abgeschlagenheit 50 prozent
klagten über kopfschmerzen 1 prozent
klagt übernimmt knoten schwellungen und
dann kann man weiter scrollen kann sich
angucken wie das bei moderner aussieht
da waren das zum beispiel 70 prozent die
sich abgeschlagen fühlten 60 prozent
klagten über kopf und muskelschmerzen
zehn prozent klagten über fieber das
heißt da habt ihr wirklich alle daten
ganz genau aufbereitet um euch das noch
mal im detail anzugucken
und das ist eben auch eine sache die
sich in den kommentaren jetzt hier sehr
häufig die frage nach den nebenwirkungen
die frage nach dem langzeitstudien haben
wir schon beantwortet das im grunde die
studienlage sagt biologe martin stürner
ausreicht um auszuschließen dass es dort
größere folgeschäden gibt aber hier zum
beispiel exemplarisch eine frage von
hubert müller ich weiß jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht ob sie die beantworten
können herr stürmer hat der russische
impfstoff mehr oder schlimmere
nebenwirkungen den haben wir hier in der
app noch nicht mit aufbereitet wissen
sie da was zu von dem was ich kurz quer
gelesen habe in der in der
veröffentlichung entdeckt sich das
letztendlich mit dem was er für den von
den anderen impfstoffen erkennen wenn
man übrigens mal sich an seine letzte
grippeimpfung oder irgendeine hepatitis
impfung oder diphterie tetanus impfung
zurück erinnert
dann wird man fast die gleichen symptome
gespürt haben ich glaube es gibt kaum
eine info oder dass die bekämpften den
dicken arm haben an der einstichstelle
dass es da ein bisschen schmerz das
immunsystem wird ja durch die impfung
stimuliert deswegen fühle ich mich
einfach mal ein tag etwas schwächer habe
vielleicht auch mal kopfschmerzen und
gegebenfalls sogar fieber das ist eine
völlig normale reaktion des immunsystems
auf die impfung das ist ja gewollt dass
unser immunsystem anfängt zu arbeiten
und das ist behalten impfstoffen gleich
und es wäre er sage ich mal einen fuß
seien bedenklich wenn man fast gar
nichts oder gar nichts spüren würde weil
das hieße dann dass vielleicht das
immunsystem überhaupt nicht anspringt
auf denen auch die impfung und insofern
sind das alles völlig normale dinge und
da wird sich sputnik 5 oder sputnik wie
oder v wie man ihn nennen mag nicht
unterscheiden
jetzt gibt es hier eine frage die auch
immer wieder auftauchenden diskussion
todesfälle nach impfungen ich nehme
exemplarisch für den kommentar von gerd
marx der sagt es gibt bereits fälle dass
ältere menschen nach der impfung
verstorben sind wie ist der stand der
ermittlungen und gibt es einen direkten
zusammenhang
diese fälle sind von paul ehrlich
institut oder mit zufälligen entsprechen
zuständigen nationalen behörden in den
anderen ländern genauestens geprüft
worden weil das wollen wir natürlich
ausschließen dass durch die impfung
todesfälle entstehen und in saalfeld
konnte entwarnung gegeben werden dass
zwar ein zeitlicher zusammenhang zur
impfung besteht aber keine ursächliche
das heißt also die impfung selber war
für diese todesfälle nicht
verantwortlich einige beispiele sind ja
dass menschen dann an kroner verstorben
sind
wir wissen alle wenn ich mich heute
impfen lasse bin ich morgen nicht immun
das mein körper braucht eine zeit um
immunität aufzubauen mindestens zwölf
tage beim biotech impfstoff wenn ich in
der zwischenzeit im altersheim ich an
strecke mit corona ein mensch von über
90 bin vielleicht auch
begleiterkrankungen kabel habe ich
trotzdem vor hoher wahrscheinlichkeit zu
versterben
ich wäre dann aber auch mit der
infektion ohne die impfung verstorben
insofern kann ich auch da entwarnung
geben
jetzt gibt's natürlich große diskussion
gerade um die mutationen die teilweise
auch schon bei uns identifiziert wurden
hier gibt es zwei fragen dazu von
andreas youtube zum beispiel wirken denn
die einzelnen impfstoffe bei diesen
mutationen wissen wir da schon mehr da
wir wissen relativ
von biotech und moderner was die
sogenannte englische und die
südafrikanische variante angeht bei
beiden sind diese impfstoffe noch
wirksam
dadurch dass die brasilianische mutter
hatte sich von der südafrikanischen in
wichtigen schlüssel dazu nicht so groß
unterscheidet gehe ich davon aus dass
das auch für die brasilianische variante
gilt wir sehen ein bisschen reduziert
ihre wirksamkeit zum beispiel beim
nowaks impfstoff ein tod impfstoff der
jetzt auch bald auf den markt kommen
wird also man muss da tatsächlich ein
bisschen genauer hinschauen nicht alle
impfstoffe scheinen gleich gut gegen die
neuen varianten zu wirken aber zumindest
für die aktuell zugelassenen mr anna
impfstoffe gehe ich davon aus von den
daten die wir gesetzt haben dass sie
voll wirken voll wirksam sind und dann
noch eine frage zu der mutation kommt
auch auf youtube begünstigen denn diese
unterschiedlichen impfstoffe dass das
virus noch schneller mutiert
ich ergänze jetzt mal eben weil sich das
virus eventuell dann anpasst vor allem
wenn es von verschiedenen seiten
beschossen wird
es wird ja eigentlich von verschiedenen
herstellern beschossen aber mit dem
gleichen proteine also alle hersteller
haben gemeinsam dass sie das so genannte
oberflächenprotein dass es antigen das
protein benutzen um immunität zu
erzeugen dafür geben wir natürlich und
das stimmt eindruck auf das virus aus
aber das ist jetzt auch in einer
richtung gehend sich sozusagen in
unserem impfstoffen zu entziehen
wenn wir nicht schnell genug sind und
dem virus zeit geben kann es durchaus
passieren dass irgendwann varianten
auftauchen so dass der impfstoff so gut
wie gar nicht mehr wirkt der vorteil
aber der mrm stoffe zum beispiel ist
dass die sehr schnell nachjustiert
werden können und man dann im prinzip
über der influenza viren vierfach
impfstoff haben dann eben nach
beziehungsweise mit mit mehrfachem
stoffen herangehen kann abschließende
frage die ich ja auch gerade schon
gesehen haben wenn man mit einem
impfstoff geimpft wurde der weniger
wirksam ist in anführungszeichen kann
man sich später mit einem wirksamen
impfstoff nachimpfen lassen oder sollte
man so lange warten bis ein neuer
impfstoff verfügbar ist eine eine sehr
gute frage wir haben
wir haben aktuell überhaupt keine daten
über das sogenannte crossover das heißt
ich fange zum beispiel mit astrazeneca
an und macht die zweite impfung mit
biotech oder irgendwas in der richtung
die daten gibt es noch überhaupt nicht
insofern muss man sich aktuell erst mal
an das halten was was gilt sprich habe
ich mit bayern tag angefangen mache ich
mit bayern tag weiter und umgekehrt
es wird über die zeit sicherlich die
möglichkeiten geben da auch zu kreuzen
aber da fehlen uns aktuell komplett die
daten gut dann haben wir hoffentlich
jetzt viele fragen beantwortet das
bleibt natürlich immer noch einzelne
rest frage die dann sehr spezifisch sind
da bitte ich um verständnis wenn wir da
nicht drauf eingehen können aber ich
bedanke mich für eure rege beteiligung
für ihre ganzen fragen auch für die
skeptischen fragen die wir wichtig
finden natürlich und an der stürmer der
uns wieder rede und antwort gestanden
hat in dieser schwierigen situation
herstellen auf vielen dank und noch
einen schönen abend an sie sehr gerne
ebenfalls und dann auch an euch vielen
dankeschönabend an euch und bis zum
nächsten stream wo wir wieder versuchen
werden eure fragen hiermit zu
beantworten bis dahin sage ich mach's
gut und tschüss